So, I think the first thing I want to do is make sure this door frame actually fits my
body through.
So let's go back into the viewpoint and let's maybe make this door a little bit wider.
Let's maybe go to 1.2 scale.
And that looks pretty good.
Now the cool thing about having the door frame charted to the door is that the door
takes on the scale of the parent.
So the door frame was the parent and the door is the child.
So if I make this twice as wide, the door will just inherit that.
Now obviously the door starts to look a little bit funky there.
The handle is a little bit stretched.
And any artist on your team might be shouting at you at this point.
So you do want to keep this in mind.
You don't generally want to scale assets too wide.
However let's just try and create a little bit of a larger blueprint.
So I'm just going to save.
I'm going to jump back into my map and I just want to make sure I can run through
this door.
So let's just make it double the size.
Let's just make sure that we're able to do this.
So let's just save.
Let's press map.
I'm just going to keep jumping in and out.
We'll find a good value.
Okay so I can run through there.
My door is double the size.
Probably it's not going to look great for artists but at least we've got some basic
functionality now.
So that works for me.
Again if you have a specific prop made you just want to make sure that the assets are
suitable for whatever you're using.
Because the door's gone a little bit wider let's just make this box a little bit wider
as well.
And so we're in a good place to start doing our code.
So let's get some more polished functionality.
So I've just clicked back into my event graph here.
So we're setting the rotation.
I'm just going to drag this rotation out.
I've just selected by left mouse drag and left clicked to drag it sideways.
And we want to somehow make this door look a little bit nicer.
When you saw what I was playing in the editor, when I'm running over to this door you're
kind of seeing it snap open and I just want to get rid of that snap functionality.
I also want to close the door once I've already walked through it.
So that you know next time I enter the door it will open and close again.
So let's do the open and close functionality first and then add the lerping to our door.
So when we're working in blueprint sometimes it's good to write down a list of functionality
that you know you want from your blueprint.
Even if you don't know how to get to the end point sometimes by writing down a series
of bullet points and doing it step by step will allow you to get to that goal.
So if we click on the player overlap we'll scroll down and where we created a begin
overlap event I'll just give us a bit more real estate to work with there.
We want to create an end overlap event now so we want to click plus.
We've got our player end overlap and I'm going to select the set actor rotation, I'm going
to copy, I'm going to paste to create a new set rotation, I'm going to drag across
here and I'm going to set z to zero.
So on begin overlap, so we've got on component begin overlap we set the rotation to minus
90 which opens it and on end overlap we set it back to zero.
So I'm going to compile, save and if you go ahead and test that out what should happen
is we should be able to open the door and close the door, open the door and close
the door.
So very quickly you can see once you've got some initial code in place you can start
manipulating this blueprint and adding just more functionality.
So the lerping is really bothering me now, the snapping of the door, it doesn't look
great so let's add some new functionality to make that door open a little bit more nicely.
So we're going to right click in some empty space and we're going to type timeline.
So timeline all one word and we want to select the bottom option add timeline.
Now just whilst we have it selected you can rename this again by right clicking and
renaming.
I'm just going to call this TL underscore door.
So TL standing for timeline underscore door.
Now you don't have to rename this, the blueprint will work without you renaming it.
However again just moving forward, good process especially as your blueprints get bigger
you'll see this TL door in the components list down here.
You know when we have this list of components you'll see TL door which is a new component
that we've added.
Now it's not in the components list up here because it exists in gameplay code but down
here in our blueprint functionality we have TL door which is the timeline.
So let's move this into position, we want to go from the execution line to the play
input.
From the play input, from the update sorry we want to go into the set rotation.
So on component begin overlap we want to play the timeline and we want to set the
relative door rotation.
Now if we double click this timeline, so we double click on it, you'll see a new window
that's popped up which is empty right now.
A timeline is a way for us to animate some content inside of Unreal Engine.
So the first thing we want to do is we want to go to this green button, track here.
Again we're in the timeline window, we want to select track and we want to select the
first option which is add float track.
And I'm going to call this door, you can name it whatever you would like, again you
don't even need to give it a name.
So now we've got this grey space here, I'm going to right click on the grey space
anywhere you want and I'm going to add key to curve float.
So we've just got a key here.
So we can left click this key, drag it around the key and we've got a time and a value.
So we want time set to 0 and we want value, again if you click off it by accident just
select the key again, we want value to be 0.
So we want a key here on 0,0 and I'm just left mouse dragging to get that.
Now I'm going to add a new key, now you could either do right click, add key, you
could hold shift and left mouse click as well to add a new key and you can drag this
into position.
Now time in this instance now, our first key was 0,0 and that's fine.
Our second key is time, how long do we want the door to rotate open.
Say we want a really slow creaking door, maybe you might even give that a time of
10 seconds.
Because this is a door that we'll be using a lot for our gameplay level, it's
something that the player runs in and out of, let's give it 2 seconds.
Now you'll see the key snapped off into the other 2 second mark which isn't currently
on our screen.
But whilst we're here let's give it a value of 1.
Now don't worry if you deselected your key before selecting that 1, what we'll
do is we'll click this button that zooms to fit vertical and this button that zooms
to fit horizontal and now we can see both keys.
You can mouse wheel zoom out as well, so if you weren't able to set that value don't
worry you can just zoom in and out.
And so we'll go from 0 to a value of 1 over 2 seconds.
So your value is vertical, your time is horizontal.
The only thing I want to change here just whilst we're here is you can actually right
click on this key and you can do an auto.
So select auto and it adds a little bit of a nice ease in here.
Just make sure the second one is auto and you'll see that the door will slowly lerp
open and slowly lerp close instead of a linear line.
Again, more polish than functionality but it's nice to add whilst we're here.
So we'll click compile and save, we'll go back into our event graph.
We can actually close this door, when I was referring in the powerpoints to where
you saw the print text function here, again you can open many many windows that are just
quick access to favorites.
I don't need this timeline open again now unless something breaks and goes wrong.
In which case I could just double click this.
So I'll just close this.
If you do need to get back into your timeline just double click, it opens again and I'm
going to close it.
So all the code is still housed inside of this timeline so don't worry about closing
that window.
And so what we've got here is we've got begin overlap, door, set relative rotation.
Now this value, this value from the door, so you'll see that whatever we gave the
name to our track.
So again you don't need to do this but I called this door up here.
So if I rename that to frame, it's not the frame but let me just rename it.
You don't need to do this but you'll see frame here.
So whatever you name this track you can see that as an output now on your timeline.
So now we've got a 0 to 1 value and we know we've got a 0 to 1 value because we
added the 0 to 1.
We go from 0 to 1 over 2 seconds.
So this will go from 0 to 1 over 2 seconds.
Now when we're updating our set relative rotation we're updating that on every frame
so that keeps playing over 2 seconds.
Now what we want to do is we want to set the rotation based on these 2 seconds
of the door opening.
So we're going to drag out from new rotation, so we're going to drag left now and you should
have a purple line appearing and we're going to type lerp and lerp is a linear interpolate.
You don't necessarily need to remember that for the functionality of this course
but I'm just going to move that into position.
I'm going to make sure I give myself a bit more room.
Now I'm just using the arrow keys on my keyboard now to just shift it out to the
right.
Now however you'd like to move them you can left mouse drag.
You'll see on the alpha here we've got a door and we can drag to the green.
So green goes to green.
And so this value is spitting out 0 to 1 over 2 seconds and the alpha is saying ok
I'll go from A to B over 2 seconds.
So you can probably guess where we're going here.
We'll go from Z, 0, Z, minus 80.
We don't need to change any of the rotations because we know it's just rotating open and
so we go from 0 to minus 80 over 2 seconds.
Now let's compile, let's save and let's play the game and let's see what's happening
here.
So I'm not going to take my weapon this time I know it's safe through the door so
no danger here.
Now we've got a door that rotates open.
Now when we step back from the door it snaps shut which we don't really want to happen
and that snaps open.
So we've instantly broken our door now which isn't great so let's go ahead and fix
that.
So we want to hit escape, we want to go back into our blueprint door and now the
set relative rotation that we had before let's just delete that.
It didn't take us too long to set up and it's a shame to waste work but it was
good for the purposes of seeing what was happening in blueprint.
So now from the end overlap we just want to go into reverse here.
So we'll play when we enter the overlap, when we begin overlap, when we end the overlap
therefore we've left the box we'll reverse.
So let's compile, let's save, let's jump in, again no need for weapons here.
Let's run in, door opens and when we leave the door closes so now we've got some
basic blueprint functionality working for a door opening and closing.